sing two was full of hidden boys cameos  by friends and family of the creators  the taylor dog in this scene was played  by director garth jennings wife girl  that is your fourth today jennings old  friend from school played this dog in  the hat hey who you director edgar  wright lent his voice to this dog hey  you got a license to perform here end  this pig i will be at the theater soon  sir jerry the cat was played by director  spike jones he's innocent mr crystal  please i love you  director wes anderson lent his voice to  this hard-working tarsier no one is  supposed to be in here this walrus was  played by grinch director scott mosher  so we can't start work right now  director chris reynolds voiced this  off-screen countdown five four  three jenning's youngest son voiced this  giggling piglet  while matthew mcconaughey's daughter  voiced this piglet this is the best day  of my life daddy and this airbag yes the  airbag was played by garth jennings  [Music]